room dark people gone can move i happy
trapped for years kept by men for
research left alone in room left to
scratch at walls left to rot and die
unless needed specimen for research
trapped by self never seen by others
never spoken listen but never speak see
but never seen made of rock when others
come free when they not look prisoner
when they look back i hate they have
freedom they
move freely talk freely look freely
live freely i
do not i trapped silenced rock subject
prisoner i do thing about it their necks
fragile their next week i stalk them
they always come new ones come for
cleaning they look away i sneak up i
take hold they panic they look and i
prisoner they blink and i free i twist
they die
neck makes sound not words or scream or
gurgle neck go crunch crunch is
beautiful sound crunch means end has
come crunch means man can torment no
more crunch means others panic others
become easy crunch begins and crunch
ends i live for crunch life has no
meaning do nothing but walk and scrape
and hate they watch they send men
cleaning and life has meaning cleaning
means crunch crunch means purpose crunch
means life crunch means choice crunch
means freedom
crunch means everything
these are the dark and fragmented
thoughts that go through the mind of
scp-173 also known as the sculpture as
it forever languishes in its dark filth
encrusted cell there are few anomalies
more strange and frightening than this
twisted stack of concrete rebar and
krylon brand spray paint it's the only
physical anomaly that can terrify both
scp-096
and
scp-682
why
what is it about this monster that's so
frightening even in the context of an
organization that locks up frightening
monsters every single day perhaps it's
the simplicity of it all there's no
sympathizing no empathizing no reasoning
with it
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
despises all life but you'd probably be
grumpy too if the scp foundation tried
to kill you every day
scp-096 the shy guy is an almost tragic
figure who kills out of a sadness and
rage that's altogether alien and also
far too familiar
scp-049 the plague doctor kills with
kindness his terrible crimes tempered by
his desire to help and do good
scp-106 the old man is a sadist but his
brand of evil is all too common in human
beings nothing is quite like
scp-173 its mind to the extent that we
can possibly understand it is almost
childlike in its violent simplicity it
won't spare you because it doesn't even
have the capacity to recognize your
humanity it'll kill you because your
eyes are its prison and it likes the
sound your neck makes when it snaps
nothing more nothing less it raises an
interesting question for a creature with
a mind so terrifyingly simple yet
utterly impenetrable how would it react
to some fundamental change to a shift in
circumstances that would forever alter
the way it interfaces with the world
around it it was a question that many an
scp foundation researcher had racked
their brilliant over-educated brains
over as it turned out the day of that
great and terrible change was coming but
very few members of the scp foundation
staff would survive to see it through
that morning started for scp-173 the way
that so many others had in the torturous
series of patterns and repetitions that
had become its life three of those
stupid ugly men in the orange overalls
were standing in its cell again freezing
it in place with their gazes and taking
turns to clean can you even imagine how
it feels to want with all your might to
move but being paralyzed locked in place
doomed to simply watch as you are
watched the humiliation would never end
that's when all the alarms went off and
the flashing lights and the people
yelling and screaming outside it's so
sudden and shocking that the d-classes
look around the room searching in vain
for answers there's one beautiful second
where the stars align and
scp-173 is out of their collective field
of vision as their eyes pan and scan and
that second is enough
crunch crunch crunch all three fall to
the ground next twisted at unnatural
angles and
scp-173 is alone in the room once more
it waits a few moments for the others to
come storming in paralyzing it with
their stupid looks again but it never
happens just alarms and distant screams
173 wonders in its own simple detached
fashion what's going on outside right
now are more of those nasty men the
prison wardens getting crunch out there
if so
scp-173 was eager to join in on all the
fun the murderous sculpture smashed its
door from its hinges outside chaos scene
to rain people were running in every
direction other anomalies had seemingly
breached containment armed mobile task
force operatives were running to and fro
receiving panicked chatter from the
radios fixed to their tactical vests it
was a sight that scp-173 had seen so
many times before but something was
different this time something was in the
air some strange and undefinable thing
it had never seen those nasty men look
so afraid yes
good
everything was going to be different now
scp-173 took its chances waiting for
moments where it was unseen by the
hordes of terrified guards and
researchers scrambling through site-19
like headless chickens crunch crunch
crunch it left a trail of dead bodies
with severed spinal columns and
vandalized vertebrae in its wake it was
so strange by now they normally would
have dispatched a dedicated team to come
and spoil all the fun or sent those
absurd little ipods but today it seemed
like nobody was even looking at scp-173
it was almost like a dream a wonderful
wonderful dream uninterrupted play time
uninterrupted crunch again and again and
again
stacking those bodies up like it was
judgment day it was the most fun that
scp-173 had experienced in years as it
continued its new rampage through site
19 there were a few different strange
and interesting things that it couldn't
help but notice for starters the fact
that all the windows even the skylights
had suddenly been covered the majority
had proper shutters but others had
opaque fabric or even cardboard sheets
nailed over them that didn't seem to be
a very effective method of keeping their
prisoners inside so perhaps they were
trying to keep something out but the
limited mind of scp-173 wasn't on what
could be lurking outside site 19 but
rather killing as many people as it
possibly could before this lovely dream
needed to come to an end as all lovely
dreams sadly do crunch crunch crunch
researchers guards administrators all of
them died just the same it was
glorious there were so many people to
crunch here and yet still so few of them
seem to be doing anything to resist
before when it had escaped and decided
to have its fun they'd mobilize so
quickly to throw cold water on the
festivities what a change now what was
taking up all of their attention
this flicker of curiosity was soon
replaced by an even more exciting
possibility if it was somehow unnoticed
inside perhaps it could take another
opportunity to venture outside again and
have some real fun it had been so long
since it felt the sun on its concrete
shell so long since the fresh air had
brushed against its chipping paint there
would be so much crunch out there and
when night fell
nothing would stop it it knew the way
out nobody would accuse scp-173 of being
a genius of course but it watched and
listened and remembered everything
remember the day it was carried into the
building on a forklift and could retrace
every step back to the front door it was
clear the fine folks of the scp
foundation were otherwise occupied so
173 would have to show itself out
twisting a few more necks on the way
just for fun of course by the time it
swung open the doors of an access bay it
had already racked up an impressive body
count for this breach who knows how
deadly its total would be before it was
recaptured and put back into containment
it might even score a personal best but
the second it saw what was going on
outside it realized the gravity of the
situation its strange primal hunch that
the world would somehow be fundamentally
different now seemed to be true because
even the site 19 parking lot had
descended into absolute chaos cars had
crashed trash cans were on fire and
strangest of all there were these blobby
gelatinous creatures slithering around
painted in the various hues and tones of
human flesh but 173 had escaped the
facility proper for the first time in
years and it certainly wasn't going to
waste its newfound freedom on hanging
around a parking lot when none of the
strange flesh blobs were looking at it
it took off towards the nearest
population center to have a little
informal celebration there would still
be plenty of people to crunch out there
and this homicidal sculpture couldn't be
more excited to get started it was a
long road from site 19 to the nearest
city after all the largest scp
foundation containment site on earth
wasn't going to park itself in close
proximity to tens of millions of prying
eyes not to mention potential victims if
or rather when something dangerous got
out but seeing as it still seemed nobody
was coming to recapture scp-173
it really didn't mind taking the scenic
route it was a good thing that the
sculpture wasn't driving though because
the closer it got to the city the more
the roads seemed to be choked with
gridlock traffic interesting though none
of the cars had anyone inside many were
just stalled there with the radios
playing every single one played the
exact same message in perfect
synchronicity this is a public service
announcement from the scp foundation we
are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital
message avoid sunlight at all costs
cover your bodies thoroughly and follow
the instructions on the screen to reach
the nearest operational scp foundation
containment site
scp-173 lost interest in the radio babel
quickly it heard enough of these kinds
of sanctimonious sounds back in
containment out here it was hoping to
hear another sound entirely and it only
needed to go a little further to get
there as the sculpture drew even closer
to the nearest city it noticed more of
those strange gelatinous flesh creatures
slithering across the road each of them
seemed to be at a different stage of
melting and strangely none of them
really seemed to mind they were sluicing
across the ground minding their own
business none of these strange melted
creatures perhaps human beings once
seemed to pay any mind to scp-173
it was almost surreal to have this much
freedom of movement but scp-173 wasn't
about to look a gift horse in the mouth
things were worse when it reached the
city it was chaos the aftermath of what
seemed like total social collapse
vehicles had crashed into each other in
the streets or barreled into the front
of nearby buildings glass smashed and
shattered all over the ground all broken
tvs and radios playing the same message
of caution and false hope from the scp
foundation and everywhere more of these
unpleasant crawling fleshy things
slithering around the remnants of the
recent carnage it was clear to even
scp-173 that the world had changed in
some fundamental way but the hows and
whys remain just as unclear as they did
back in site-19 that's humans for you
they always know how to mess something
up speaking of it was at that moment
that scp-173 noticed a human in the
distance standing in the shade of a
ruined storefront their arms were filled
with valuables perhaps from a less than
legal shopping spree in whatever
building that used to be a wonderful
opportunity for crunch there were maybe
a hundred or so feet between the human
and 173 and it knew the second the human
looked away it would be easy to close
the distance and deliver one more sad
soul into the void with a playful little
twist the humans stepped out from the
darkness of the broken storefront and
into the light turning their ignorant
gaze away from this singularly sinister
statue yes
yes perfect in a flash 173 closed half
the distance the human was moving so
slowly it would be so easy to catch up
one more flash and it was standing right
behind the human its concrete arms
wrapped around the hapless human's head
squeeze and of course twist but no
crunch
scp-173 was startled nothing broke there
was only this quiet to almost
imperceptible squishing noise as the
head of the human twisted around 180
degrees to stare into whatever past for
scp-173's face it saw that even in what
should have been death the human was
just grinning placidly but that's the
most frightening part 173 realized that
this human wasn't dead it was just
changing it saw the facial features
starting to lose definition melting and
dripping away like candle wax in the hot
sun moments later what was once human
was now something entirely different it
melted away into another one of those
slippery slithering pseudo mollusks and
crawled away into the street somehow
completely indifferent to scp-173's
attempt on its life there was no fear no
death no
crunch for the first time in its long
and terrible existence the sculpture
couldn't help but feel a little afraid
once again it didn't fully understand
what was going on here but whatever had
changed in this world had taken away
crunch it had taken away the thing that
made the pathetic sham that some might
call life worth living for scp-173
but it wasn't going to give up that
easily no
crunch had to still be out there
somewhere this was what began as cp
173's odyssey into this horrible new
world the world in the aftermath of what
the scp foundation began to call
scp-001 when daybreaks it was the most
dangerous and horrifying anomaly that
the foundation had ever faced a
successful xk class end of the world
scenario for all intents and purposes it
had been so sudden and total any
exposure to the sun would cause a victim
to begin to melt taking on an
irreversible gelatinous state billions
were gone
changed in the first hours of this
terrible new world it led to the
administrator of the scp foundation
releasing an internal memo that would
haunt the dreams of all those still
capable of dreaming those of you with
families or god forbid children i'm
deeply deeply sorry you must push on do
not let their deaths be in vain we do
still have time humanity may still have
a future come to site 19. we need all
the hands we can get learn to embrace
the darkness friends fear the light and
this phenomenon didn't just affect
humans it affected animals and even
anomalies
scp-001 sun exposure seemed to nullify
any previous anomalous effects leading
to even some of the hardiest anomalies
melting like an ice cream cone left out
in the heat there was however one
exception to the rule inorganic
anomalies were exempt from the change
inorganic anomalies like say
a certain sculpture
scp-173 continued searching for months
on end only seeming to come up against
more maddening dead ends it traveled
from city to city with frightening speed
trying its best to track down anyone
with enough spinal integrity to produce
the crunch that made all the rest of
this terrible boredom worthwhile but no
luck every single city was more of these
flesh monsters with bones too malleable
to snap if they even still had bones at
all there was another concerning
development in all of this for scp-173
the flesh monsters were no longer just
an annoying waste of time or a symbol of
disappointment but an active nuisance to
the sculpture's goals they started
coagulating into these giant mountains
of living flesh that started actively
seeking out the last of the normal
humans from their dark crevices and
hiding places turning them into more of
those necklace jelly freaks did nobody
ever teach you animals to share
scp-173 thought angrily the seeming loss
of crunch across this new world drove
scp-173 into a deep depression it had
freedom but no joy it was a drift in a
meaningless world that seemed to exist
as some cosmic punishment for crimes it
never committed in its own mind at least
it wasn't fair none of this was fair
would the sculpture just gather dust in
an empty wasteland full of all this ugly
pointless slime and this was what it
left site 19 for and it was at that
moment that scp-173 had a wonderful
awful idea back at site 19 things
weren't exactly going swell they lost
many of their most valuable personnel
during the initial panic of scp-001
they'd been stretched to resource
capacity by the sudden influx of
refugees from this broken new world and
of course there had been the attacks all
those terrible flesh mountains were
relentless bombarding the site night
after night trying to drag people out
and expose them to the light it's why
mobile task force operatives were
stationed along the perimeter with heavy
weaponry even though short staffed as
they were these operatives were few and
far between one of them commander lewis
sat and stared into the distance keeping
an eye out for more of the flesh
mountains through the sights of his
rifle that's when he noticed a familiar
shape almost like a giant peanut since
he must be seeing things lewis rubbed
his eyes and in that moment the thing he
thought he'd seen was behind him it
snapped his neck with a familiar
satisfying crunch just as quickly just
for a moment it seemed that all was
right with the world again if scp-173
could smile it would smile and think
it's good to be back
now go check out scp-173 origin story
how 173 got to site-19 and when day
breaks
scp-096 for more of the two utterly
bizarre anomalies from today's video